The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
I just wanted to briefly remind
you of some of the periodic
trends that we talked about.
As you go across the periodic
table, both the electron
affinity and the ionization
energy increase.
They increase because the
nuclear charge increases.
Remember, the potential energy
of interaction is Z times e,
where that is the nuclear
charges, times e over 4 pi
epsilon nought r.
Z increases as you go across
the periodic table here.
As you go across,
r is remaining the same because
you are essentially still in the
same shell.
And so what increases is that
attractive interaction,
meaning the electrons are more
strongly bound,
meaning ionization energy and
electron affinity increases as
you go across.
And this also means,
as you go across,
r, the radius decreases.
The radius decreases again
because Z increases.
The nucleus is pulling the
electrons in closer.
Since they are all in the same
shell, r is remaining the same.
And so, the overall effect is
that the radius of the atoms
decreases.
As you go down the Periodic
Table, the ionization energy and
the electron affinity decrease.
They decrease because it is the
r dependence,
here, that takes over.
Z is, of course,
increasing, but not as fast as
r.
As you go down the Periodic
Table, you are going to shells
that, on the average,
are further out from the
nucleus.
And that dependence takes over,
causing EA and IE to decrease.
And then the radius,
of course, increases,
because, as you go down,
you are putting the electrons
into shells which are on the
average farther away from the
nucleus.
That is just a review of those
trends.
Then, finally,
I want to just define another
term, and that is the
electronegativity.
Sometimes we give that the
symbol chi.
The electronegativity is an
empirical quantity.
We are going to use Mulliken's
definition for the
electronegativity.
There is a Pauling definition.
Mulliken is a little bit more
straightforward.
And that electronegativity is
defined as one-half times the
quantity ionization energy plus
the electron affinity.
The electronegativity is
proportional to the average of
the ionization energy and the
electron affinity.
The electronegativity is a
measure of the tendency of an
atom to accept or to donate an
electron.
If you look at the Periodic
Table, here, you have atoms in
the upper right-hand corner of
the Periodic Table.
Well, they have high
electronegativities.
They are good electron
acceptors.
They have high
electronegativities because they
have high electron affinities.
Adding an electron to them
means that there is a larger
amount of energy release.
The anion is much more stable
than the neutral.
And the electron affinity is
minus that energy change,
remember from last time.
These atoms here,
with their high electron
affinities, are good electron
acceptors.
They are also good electron
acceptors because their
ionization energies are also
high, which means you have to
put in a lot of energy to pull
an electron off.
They don't like to donate
electrons, rather they are good
electron acceptors.
And then, the elements that are
in the bottom left-hand corner
of the Periodic Table have low
electronegativities.
They are good electron donors
because their ionization energy
is low in this part of the
periodic table.
You don't have to put in so
much energy to pull an electron
off.
They are also good electron
donors because their electron
affinity is low.
You don't get as much energy
back when you put an electron on
them.
These are good electron donors.
High chi, here.
These are good electron
acceptors.
And one thing you already know
probably is that some of the
strongest ionic bonds are made
between elements in these two
corners of the periodic table.
An ionic bond,
as we are going to talk about,
is one in which the electrons
are not shared equally.
And so these strong ionic bonds
occur between elements with high
electronegativity and low
electronegativity.
So that's that concept.
And then, finally,
one other kind of odd and end
here.
That is this term
isoelectronic.
I have listed here a bunch of
atoms and ions that are
isoelectronic.
Isoelectronic means having the
same electron structure.
All of these atoms and ions
have the electron configuration
1s 2 2s 2 2p 6.
For example,
this nitrogen,
N minus 3,
it has added three electrons to
be nitrogen minus three.
It has added three electrons to
get this electron configuration,
this rare gas configuration,
this octet configuration which
is a very stable configuration.
Aluminum has three electrons
removed to obtain this
particular electron
configuration.
The common ions,
ions that you see commonly in
nature, are ions that,
in fact, do have this octet
configuration,
this electron configuration of
an inert gas.
For example,
you will often see compounds
with nitrogen minus three.
You won't very often see a
compound with nitrogen minus two
or nitrogen minus one
because those are not
as stable as nitrogen minus
three,
given this rare gas or the
octet configuration.
All right.
That is just a little odd and
end.
I just wanted to make sure that
everybody was on the same level
with the understanding of the
word isoelectronic there.
Well, now what I thought I
would do is talk a little bit
about wave functions and the
usefulness of wave functions.
This is going to be on the side
boards here.
I wanted to just show you in
kind of simple terms how a wave
function actually determines the
intensity of some transition.
Many of you have asked me about
the intensities of transitions,
and so I thought I would show
you just a little bit about how
these wave functions determine
the intensities of transitions.
First of all,
I have to explain this diagram
to you.
This is going to be a diagram
for a hydrogen atom.
That is what we are going to
talk about here.
What we are going to start with
is an energy level diagram for
the hydrogen atoms.
That is what this axis is.
And so, I am plotting in that
diagram, energy,
going up.
And I plot the energy level for
n equals 1.
I plot the energy level for n
equals 2, n equals 3,
all the way up to n equals 235,
which is really very close to
zero.
That is part of what is on this
plot right here,
n equals 1, n equals 2,
n equals 3.
But then, what is also
typically done on the same plot
is that the potential energy of
interaction is plotted as a
function of r.
And so, on this axis here,
kind of superimposed,
is this distance r.
And we plot often the potential
energy of interaction.
The potential energy of
interaction kind of looks like
that.
This potential energy of
interaction is the Coulomb
interaction, minus e squared 4
pi epsilon nought times r.
That is what that line is on
this plot.
Then what we do is we actually
plot the form of the wave
function, kind of on top of the
energy levels.
What we do is to say,
for example,
take the n equals 1 wave
function, which starts at r
equals 0 at some finite value
and it is just an exponential
decay.
And we plot it on this diagram,
but we use the n equals 1
energy here as the value of Psi
equals 0.
In other words,
the n equals 1 wave function
looks kind of like that.
This level here is Psi equals
This is the value of Psi,
whatever it is,
at r equals 0,
and there is just an
exponential decay.
We plot the wave function on
top of that energy level.
In other words,
this is a complex diagram here.
You are going to see,
if you take any course beyond
this, this diagram a lot,
with energy levels and wave
functions plotted on top of
them.
And then, the n equals 2 wave
function is plotted on top of
the n equals 2 energy level.
Again, at r equals 0,
it is some finite value and
then it drops.
At some value of r,
we have a node for n equals 2
here.
The n equals 2 is the Psi
equals 0.
Right here, you have a radial
node.
Then it goes up and then it
comes back.
It goes down to a negative
value and then comes back up.
That is n equals 2.
And so forth and so on.
n equals 3 looks like this.
It has two radial nodes.
That is what that diagram is
showing here.
And then we get to n equals
Here is the wave function.
Is this is a hydrogen atom and
you have n equals 235,
how many radial nodes do you
have?
This wave function is passing
through this origin 234 times.
That is the wave function.
And then it tails off.
There is always an exponential
dependence there.
That is what that wave function
looks like.
Now, how do these relate to the
intensity of some transition?
Well, the intensity of a
transition is related to the
overlap between the wave
function of the initial state
and the wave function of the
final state.
What do I mean by overlap?
Well, by overlap,
I mean you take the wave
function, here,
of the initial state,
so I am going to pretend we
have a hydrogen atom in the
state, this is its wave
function.
And that hydrogen atom is going
to be relaxing to the n equals 1
state.
What I am going to do,
to get the overlap,
is I'm going to take the
product of the wave function of
the initial state times that of
the final state,
and essentially I am going to
integrate that resulting
function.
I am going to multiply these
two wave functions together,
and I am going to integrate
over all r the resulting
function.
That is what I mean by overlap.
But there is another term here.
There is an r,
too.
That r is important.
It has to do with the
transition moment dipole.
And we won't go into that,
but it is there.
But it won't affect the
argument I am going to make for
you right now.
We take the wave function of
the initial state,
multiply it by the final state
times r, and then we integrate
this whole thing from r equals 0
to infinity and then square it.
That quantity is proportional
to the intensity of some
transition.
Let's do that.
Here is Psi n equals 235,
we are multiplying it by Psi of
n equals 0 and
actually multiplying it by r.
And what we are going to see,
if we just look at this product
here, if we just looked at Psi n
equals 235 and
Psi n equals 1,
if we just looked at that
product, we are going to
multiply this times that.
In a graphical form,
it is going to look like this.
It is going to go up,
down, up, down,
up, down.
It is going to oscillate and
then tail off in an exponential
way because we are multiply this
up, down, up,
down, up down times this
exponential decay.
It is going to look something
like that.
But now, we are going to
integrate this resulting curve.
What you can see is that the
area above this curve is equal
to the area below this curve,
approximately.
And, when we integrate
something, we are calculating
the area underneath the curve.
These positive areas are going
to cancel these negative areas.
The result is that this
integral is going to be very
small.
And the result is that the
intensity of that line is very
low.
The intensities are
proportional to this overlap,
the overlap of the initial
state wave function and the
final state wave function.
And you can see,
here, graphically,
how if you integrate that
product in this case,
the positive areas cancel the
negative areas,
and you don't have a very
intense transition.
However, suppose we look at the
transition from n equals 3 to n
equals 2.
Well, here is the n equals 3
wave function,
here is the n equals 2 wave
function.
And our intensity expression
says that we have to multiply
these two.
Let's do that.
Let's multiply n equals 3 times
n equals 2, here.
Well, the result,
if you excuse my not so great
drawing, is we start out with a
very positive function here.
But then we have two negatives
here, which make it a little bit
less negative.
But then, we have a positive,
here, times a negative,
and what that makes is a large
area that is negative.
And, if we go and integrate
that, now we don't have the same
cancellation of positive and
negative areas.
We integrate that,
and that transition energy is
large.
Or, that area is large,
therefore the intensity of that
transition is large.
Bottom line,
that is one of the elements
that dictates the intensity of a
transition.
It is also one of the elements
that dictates the intensity of
your photoelectron spectra.
Somebody asked me about it the
other day.
I had drawn lines in the
photoelectronic spectra that
were of the same intensity,
1s, 2s, 2p 6.
Somebody said,
well, you have more electrons
in the 2p state.
Why don't you have a larger
number of electrons coming off?
The answer is,
that is part of what goes into
determining the intensity of the
transition, but there is more to
it.
It is not just the number of
electrons.
Here is one of the elements
that goes into determining the
intensity of some transition.
It is the wave functions and
the overlap between the final
and the initial state.
And then, I just wanted to also
show you, here,
for this atom in the n equals
235 state, I plotted just for
fun, kind of schematically,
what the radial probability
distribution would look like.
That is just r squared times
the radial part squared.
And, of course,
since the wave function goes
like this, oscillates,
that is what the radial
probability distribution is
going to do.
And you are going to see
nodes here, 234 values of r,
that is going to make the wave
function be equal to zero.
And then way out here,
you are going to have a
feature.
That last feature,
here, is going to have the
maximum probability,
and that is your value of r
that is most probable.
It turns out for n equals
that the most probable value of
r is 43,800 angstroms.
That is about 4.38x10^-6
meters.
This is a really large hydrogen
atom, n equals 235.
Do they exist?
The answer is yes,
they do exist.
They exist, particularly in
outer space, where there is lots
of UV radiation to get these
hydrogen atoms up into these
very excited states.
And they exist in deep outer
space, where the temperatures
are pretty cold.
And you need those cold
temperatures because this
hydrogen atom is not very stable
in n equals 235.
And, if you went and calculated
here, I am going to draw a line,
here.
This is going to be n equals
235, and this is the zero of
energy.
This energy difference here is
about 4x10^-23 joules.
Whereas, at room temperature,
we will just talk about the
thermal energy,
thermal energy is about
4x10^-21 joules.
You can see that any little
fluctuation at room temperature,
since this is two orders of
magnitude larger than what this
bound by, any little fluctuation
would kick this very weakly
bound electron up and ionize it.
And it would.
You really only see these in
environments that are very cold,
where you don't perturb what
are called Rydberg atoms
sometimes.
I think in the laboratory the
largest Rydberg atom that has
been made is n equals 180 or n
equals 200 or so.
Anyway, that was really just
for fun that I wanted to tell
you about that.
Now, there is another little
tidbit that I want to talk to
you about that has to do with
how knowing something about the
energy levels in an atom leads
to a nice practical device,
like a helium neon laser.
We have to take a look at the
neon energy levels.
And so we have another
discharge lamp here,
and we have some more of these
glasses, here,
so that you can resolve the
neon lines here.
The TAs will get them out.
Here is our neon discharge
lamp.
You can resolve,
here, the neon spectrum.
The spectrum that you should
see should be what is shown on
the side walls here.
Let me turn off the lights so
that you can see it a little bit
better, hopefully.
You can see lots of lines in
the case of neon because we have
lots of different occupied
states.
The glasses that I have
actually are doing a phenomenal
job in resolving those very
closely spaced lines.
I must have a better quality
glass today.
And, if you look at the side
walls, you can see that I drew
one of those lines.
One of those emission lines is
at 632 nanometers,
which is the emission line of a
helium neon laser.
But it is really a neon
transition that we will talk
about in a moment.
I drew it as very thick on the
board.
Because when I looked at the
discharge lamp and drew that
picture, my glasses did not
resolve those lines so very
well.
And so that one looked really
thick to me.
At least my glasses,
I can really see lots and lots
of discrete lines.
But it is this transition,
632 nanometers,
that is the output of the
helium neon laser,
which is the red laser that I
use sometimes in the lecture,
here, to point.
It is the basis of the laser
that is used in the grocery
stores to scan the prices on
your items.
And it turns out that what is
going on, here,
is the following.
If you look on the side walls,
we have neon in the ground
state before we turn the
discharge on.
And then, when we turn the
discharge on,
that pumps energy into the neon
atoms such that one of those
electrons, the 2p electron,
gets promoted into the 5s
state.
And then, of course,
that atom wants to relax.
And so here it comes again.
That 5s state relaxes.
That electron relaxes to the 3p
state.
And it is actually that
transition that occurs at 632.8
nanometers, the basis of the
helium neon laser.
It is that transition,
from the 5s to the 3p.
It is not all the way down,
but ultimately,
of course, that state relaxes.
But what is going on in the
helium neon laser?
Well, in the helium neon laser,
we have a discharge ignited
where we have a lot of neon
atoms here in this excited
state, with the one electron in
the 5s state right as I show
you.
And that is emitting,
a photon comes out.
But what is happening here is
that the photon that is emitted
is able to, because of the
construction of this laser,
contact or to interact with
another neon atom in this same
excited state,
that 2p 5 5s state.
That photon interacts with this
excited atom.
When it interacts with that
excited atom,
what happens is that the photon
stimulates that excited atom to
actually emit a photon of the
same energy.
This photon stimulates this
excited atom to release its
energy right at that time.
The result is that you have two
photons coming out.
They are going to come out in
the same direction and they are
going to be what is called
coherent.
That is, their phases are going
to match.
If you think now of the photon
as a wave, they are going to be
coherent.
And the result is that you are
going to have some radiation
that is going to be twice as
intense because they are
coherent.
They are in phase.
And then, what happens is that
these two photons,
they each then interact with
another neon atom in this same
excited state.
And each of those photons
stimulates another atom to emit
photons.
And the result is now that you
have four photons being emitted,
the same frequency,
same direction,
and same phase.
And it is in this way that we
amplify the light in any kind of
laser.
This is what is going on,
this process of simulated
emission.
Where you have a photon that
now is exactly the frequency of
the energy difference of the
transition that you are going to
make in this excited atom.
This stimulates that atom to
emit a photon.
The two photons then come off
coherently.
And then, these two interact
with two other atoms.
Now you have four photons that
are coming off.
That is the process of
amplification in any type of
laser.
Of course, in order to make
this work, you have to have a
lot of these excited neon atoms
around because you have to be
able to have a photon interact
with them before they just emit
spontaneously.
This is stimulated emission.
The other kind of emission that
we were talking about is
spontaneous emission.
In other words,
you have to have a high
concentration of these excited
neon atoms so that the photons
that are originally emitted
here, by just spontaneous
emission, can interact with
those excited state neon atoms
and stimulate the emission and
get this whole process rolling.
In order to produce a whole lot
of those excited neon atoms,
what happens is we add in a
little bit of helium.
It turns out that in helium
there are some excited states
that are just,
by accident,
at the same energy as this
excited state of neon.
And the helium actually
transfers its energy to the
neon, into this state,
and maintains,
then, that very high population
of neon atoms here in this
excited state.
That is the function of the
helium.
It is just the energy transfer
from the helium excited state to
the neon excited state.
It keeps the population of the
neon atoms really high.
The helium, you don't see that
emission.
That is just a helper in this
device.
It is the neon transition that
you are looking at here.
That was just a short story
about the usefulness of knowing
about the energy levels in atoms
and how ultimately you can make
a practical device because you
know something about the energy
levels of your atoms.
Well, that is going to finish
up, right now,
our discussion of atoms.
And now, it is time to move
onto one of the very important
parts of chemistry,
and that is chemical bonds and
the combination of atoms to form
a chemical bond.
That is what we are going to
start talking about,
now.
Today, what we are going to do
is just talk about the
fundamental interactions that
are present in every chemical
bond.
Let's start with that.
Let me come over here while the
lights are warming up so you can
see that board.
Suppose we have a hydrogen atom
here, nucleus a,
plus charge.
And it, of course,
has electron a attached to it.
And way out here,
we have nucleus b and electron
b that is attached to it.
And they are very far apart.
And so, in this case,
where they are very far apart,
the energy of interaction is
just the energy of interaction
between the electron and the
nucleus, the electron-nuclear
attraction.
Here it is, the
electron-nuclear attraction.
However, as we bring these two
hydrogen atoms together,
at some point this electron
that was only attracted to
nucleus a is now begins to
experience an attraction with
nucleus b.
And this electron that was
attracted only to nucleus b
experiences an interaction
whereby it is now attracted to
nucleus a.
And that kind of mutual
attractive interaction then
brings those two nuclei closer
together.
However, at the same time,
when you bring those two nuclei
closer together,
you are bringing the electrons
closer together.
And so there is an
electron-electron repulsion that
is present.
In addition,
as you bring these two nuclei
together, what is happening here
is you are having a
nuclear-nuclear repulsion.
A chemical bond is really the
sum of these three interactions
and the interplay between these
three interactions.
That is what we want to try to
look at and try to understand.
How are we going to do that?
Well, the first thing I am
going to do is I am going to
draw an energy of interaction as
a function of the distance
between the two hydrogen atoms.
I am going to take two hydrogen
atoms and I am going to call the
distance between them r.
Now, I have changed my
definition of r.
r is the distance between the
two nuclei.
It is no longer the distance
between the nucleus and the
electron.
I have just changed my
definition of r.
And I am going to plot the
energy of interaction as a
function of that distance
between the two nuclei.
Here is my energy of
interaction.
There is going to be a zero of
energy, here.
I am going to plot this as a
function of r,
and the plot is going to look
like this.
Way out here,
where r is large,
I have two separated hydrogen
atoms.
The energy, here,
is minus 2,624 kilojoules per
mole.
That is what this energy of
interaction is,
here.
Now, as I bring these two
hydrogen atoms together,
what happens is that this
energy is going to decrease.
And it is going to keep
decreasing until we get to some
point.
And then, as r gets even
smaller, that energy of
interaction is going to
skyrocket and go to infinity.
Starting about here somewhere,
where the energy of interaction
is less, is more negative than
the separated hydrogen atoms.
Well, what that means is that
we are forming a chemical bond.
The two hydrogen atoms are more
stable then when they are
separated.
The two hydrogen atoms are
bound as soon as this energy of
interaction gets more negative
than the separated atom limit.
And it keeps getting more
negative.
And, of course,
the value of r at which that
energy of interaction is a
maximum negative number,
well, that is the equilibrium
bond length.
This is the most stable value
of r at which the energy is the
lowest.
It is the most stable
configuration.
In the case of hydrogen,
that value of r is 0.74
angstroms.
In this potential energy curve,
as it is often called,
everywhere where this energy of
interaction is lower than the
separated hydrogen atom limit,
everywhere here,
this is called the attractive
region of the interaction
potential.
It is attractive because the
hydrogen atoms bound are more
stable than they are separated.
Or, the hydrogen atoms are
bound.
They are more stable than the
two hydrogen atoms separated.
We call this the attractive
region of the potential energy
curve.
We also call this region,
this attractive region,
we call that the well.
And the well depth,
here, from the bottom to the
separated hydrogen atom limit,
if you measure the energy from
the bottom up,
that energy is the bond
association energy.
We are going to call it delta E
sub d,
from the bottom here to the
separated hydrogen atom limit.
That is the bond energy.
432 kilojoules per mole is the
energy that you have to put into
the H two molecule to
separate it.
You have to get it from the
bottom of this well to the
separated hydrogen atom limit
here.
Now, you can also see,
here, as you push those two
hydrogen atoms even closer
together than the equilibrium
bond length, you can see that
the energy is going back up.
And at some point,
if you push the two hydrogen
atoms close enough together such
that the energy is equal to that
of the separated hydrogen atom,
it then becomes greater than
that of the separated hydrogen
atom.
From this value of r on,
the hydrogen atoms are no
longer bound because their
energy is greater than the
separated hydrogen atom limit.
We call this part of the
potential energy of interaction
the repulsive part.
In other words,
as you push the two hydrogen
atoms closer together,
they form a bond.
But if you push them too close,
they are going to fly apart.
They are no longer bound.
This is the general potential
energy of interaction for every
chemical bond.
Every single bond has this
general shape.
That is important.
But that shape is really a
consequence of these three
interactions that I talked about
when we started this problem,
here.
And so, what I want to try to
do is now try to dissect that
curve into the three components
that give rise to that potential
energy of interaction,
that dependence as a function
of r.
I want to pull that apart.
This energy of interaction is
the sum of the nuclear
repulsion.
Pushing the nuclei too close
together, there is a repulsive
interaction.
That is one of the
interactions.
Plus, the electron-nuclear
attraction is the attraction
between the electron and the
nucleus on which it came in.
And also between the electron
and the other nucleus.
That is the electron-nuclear
attraction.
Plus the electron-electron
repulsive.
Well, when you bring two
hydrogen atoms together those
electrons are going to repel.
That is the energy of
interaction.
It is the sum of those three
fundamental interactions.
But what I want to do is figure
out an r dependence for each one
of these interactions.
And the sum of that r
dependence should give me a
shape that looks like this.
I want to see which
interactions are important at
what values of r.
Let me start.
Let's start with the
nuclear-nuclear repulsion here.
If I wanted an r dependence for
what that nuclear-nuclear
repulsion looked like,
what would that be?
Coulomb force.
It is the repulsive Coulomb
interaction.
It is e squared over 4 pi
epsilon nought r.
This is just two like charges
that are repelling.
And so now let me draw that
repulsive interaction as a
function of r on an energy level
diagram.
Here is my energy of
interaction.
It is a function of r.
There is going to be a zero
here.
And this repulsive interaction
is going to be positive
everywhere.
It is going to be infinite here
and a one over r
dependence coming down.
This is the Coulomb
interaction.
This is the nuclear-nuclear
repulsion.
That is what it looks like as a
function of r.
That is one component.
Now, what about the other
components here?
Well, it turns out I have no
simple way of estimating what
the r dependence is for the
electron-nuclear attraction.
I have no simple way of
estimating what the r dependence
is for the electron-electron
repulsion.
And I have no simple way of
doing that for the sum of those
two terms.
Actually, the sum of these two
terms, I am going to call the
electron interactions.
Each one of these terms
involves the electrons.
The is the electron-electron
repulsion, electron-nuclear
attraction.
This term does not have any
electrons in it.
I have no simple way of telling
you or estimating what the r
dependence is of the sum of
these two terms.
However, what I can do is
figure out what the energy is
for the sum of those two
interactions at two extremes.
I can tell you what the energy
is at r equal infinity,
and then I can tell you what it
is at r equal zero.
And, therefore,
on this plot,
I am going to come in with a
value for r equal infinity and a
value for r equal zero.
I am going to draw a straight
line as an estimate for the r
dependence.
Then I am going to add them up
and see if the result looks,
in fact, like this energy of
interaction that I drew for you.
And so that is what I am going
to have to do on Friday.
I will see you on Wednesday,
if not sooner.